les siens après la 4 terre je vous le
dis on aura le directeur des programmes
de ses huit qui aura noir on va voir
s'il valide bouffe 2 / s'est vite parce
que moi j'en ai même pas parlé il va
venir ici
il nous dira si valide ou pas le prime
de leurs maux mouffe 2 donc on sais pas
peut-être qu'on va l'appeler bouffe on
fait une comprend au moins quoi on fait
une confrontés à une question bien sûr
mon bébé aller allons-y
bonjour je m'appelle valérie je déteste
votre émission
mais j'ai vu que chez vous on pouvait se
faire couper les cheveux gratuitement
donc serait-il possible d'avoir un
rendez-vous pour vendredi en fin de
matinée
[Applaudissements]
je comprends votre enthousiasme valérie
mais désolé le salon erp moon a
autrefois cyr ngai et en même temps
c'est logique mais je sais on l'a vu la
semaine dernière l'amoureux du chemin
qui nous a fait une démonstration même
mondial de la coiffure ils sont jamais
eu ça poursuit qui auraient manqué
l'émission je rappelle les faits cyril
avait pris un garçon au hasard dans le
public
avant de se rendre compte que c'était le
fils de pascal le grand frère donc
logiquement quand tu croises le fils de
quelqu'un que tu connais dans une
émission média qu'est ce que tu fais tu
écoutes du coup la coupe les cheveux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
adieu
[Musique]
ah oui t'es pas léger sur la la comme
tout ce que tu fais c'est toujours faim
[Musique]
ouaga
mais
[Musique]
coût de 1 cm à 200 m
alan doss
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
koné
on est heureux
la marque
[Applaudissements]
pas vraiment
[Musique]
je
et là c'est les initiales c'est le duc
c'est le fils
pour que dalle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je tiens à dire jeter un oeil aux
moulures il est vrai ils étaient ravis
il était comme son père était comme un
fou il a eu un succès vraie femme à
avoir vraiment joue à la nuit après est
ce que les professionnels sont pas ces
derniers qui ont récupéré la terminer
vers un salon tous les deux ah ouais bah
avec une pub comme ça c'est baba
qu'amiens ouais bon après une
démonstration aussi remarquable quand si
la demande est elle veut aussi se faire
couper les cheveux
bizarrement personne n'a répondu dans
l'équipe à part jean michel c'est vrai
que ça nous a tous surpris moi j'étais
plutôt sur la ligne de maxime guinea à
qui elle propose également regarder à
tous
[Applaudissements]
mais en même temps patrice batum c'est
la meilleure réponse qu'on pouvait faire
aspirer à ce moment là et pourtant jean
michel s'est porté volontaire pour se
faire couper les cheveux par le boucher
de tunis pourquoi est-ce que c'est
pourquoi il a accepté
pourquoi chez la réponse dans les petits
secrets de fabrication du tnp je sais
pas du tout
[Musique]
non
tennis et bien non c'est très très bien
mais ça va pas du tout c'est pas mal non
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
tél
[Musique]
leur enjeu
sandra bullock
[Musique]
non
je suis content je suis content
[Applaudissements]
comment as tu déjà poussé c'est pas mal
c'est bien moi j'aime bien ça fait un
footballeur est passé est passé chez
l'opticien isabelle et moi je trouve que
ça lui va très bien nous faire les
choses et vous qu'allez vous dire à
godefroy de montmirail et les autres et
ça c'était pour avoir un jeudi le jouet
voudra week-end je pense que c'est bon
j'ai séché par une chèvre jean michel
qui avait fait beaucoup parler lui aussi
en début de semaine en donnant une
interview où il révélé qu'ils avaient
été augmentés en fin d'année dernière à
la grande surprise de cyril enfin vous
vous souvenez nom de l'augmentation
dormez vous avez dit qui raconter
n'importe quoi
pas mal de confidences il a notamment
parlé de son salaire et il a révélé
avoir été augmentés alors je vais vous
dire la vérité juste après j'étais pas
au courant de tout ce que vous venez
bien non et pendant ces brèves
ah non je ne savais pas franchement
alors vraiment je côtoie que vous
l'appreniez ah non mais je pense que
vous avez un problème
jean-michel 20 % d'augmentation on me
les a proposés moi j'ai plutôt préféré
que ça soit distribué pour tous les
autres chroniques j'ai pas besoin
d'argent mais en tout cas c'est très
agréable augmentation on vous en
remercie tous je parle au nom de tout le
monde
j'étais pas au courant de tout ce que
vous veniez bien ce départ mais devant
l'insistance général les gens m'ont dit
si je méritais le prends le chantier
chez cd c'était une vanne au départ au
sérieux et je suis plus heureux des
hommes
eh ben je suis content mais si vous en
souvenez pas cessé parce que je pense
que vous êtes un peu fatigué fatigué
vous avez des absences on l'a beaucoup
vu la semaine dernière qu'on a reçues et
victoria silvstedt vous lui avez posé
deux fois une question de minutes
regardez bien la tête désespérée de
victoire lee à la deuxième fois mais
rien à lui dire non et que sa poche son
magasin n'a pas des canapés de ça non
mais c'est vous pensez vraiment que
c'est la patronne de château d'ax
en tout cas avec ceux déjà vu et s'est
dit qu'il y avait une faille dans la
matrice regarder comment la roue de la
fortune ou pas christophe dechavanne dit
le monde a envie de refaire de la télé
avec lui ou seulement et elle son chien
lui et son chien
ils sont 35 simplement
ah oui ça faisait longtemps déjà
j'aimais bien christophe oui c'est vrai
tant vettel offrir des roses et des
trucs en télé on était content d'avoir
victoria sur place la semaine dernière
était aussi marquée par l'absence du
petit soleil de l'émission qui élit vdev
10,1
je sais pas si tu as regardé kelly et
pendant au moins 24 heures
t'as pas été remplacés apprécié
notamment par la sublime gloria qui a su
trouver les mots pour trouver sa place
dans l'équipe
[Musique]
vous êtes maintenant ouais c'est vrai
bombe donne à ces artistes plan b
relations politiques et plans c'est
sauver les animaux et les centres
sociaux préférés
tu vois j'ai l'impression que tu
t'entends mieux qu'à gâteau qui dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au réveil
et alors aujourd'hui c'est laura laura
de quel est votre métier je suis même
d'un mannequin vous n'êtes pas dj jusque
là tout est non ça valait le coup de
sauver les animaux et les enfants du top
gênante car évidemment
ah j'adore tout de suite vous voulez
attendre on va se faire dans quelques
minutes
on suit quand vous voulez ce qui nous
arrive je ne sais pas si fragile ce soir
les bleus ont fait le top hygiène en
soutenant vous êtes ici voilà je ne sais
pas sur quel pied danser
allez on passe au top j'ai dans cette
compilation des petits moments étranges
de tpm p
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commencer mes chéris donc vous jouez
façon vous inquiétez pas dassonville
inquiétez pas je ne veux plus que lebouc
wa sallam être séparé du coup du coup
c'est par les états unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça ça a présenté bouffe sur nrj 12
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
je reste cas pas maintenant j'ai annoncé
que je respecte
pas longtemps juste après sa venue
mais vraiment d'accord mais bien sûr
mais regardez lorimer mais même les
joueurs de l'anghione les jeunes à
bouger davantage et if we ever m'attend
regardez les roches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les avis
[Musique]
alors la semaine dernière il y avait la
journée du compliment
ouais bon a priori ce jour là les
chroniqueurs et est en rtt parce que
personne n'a voulu participer même si
vous avez eu quelques tentatives comme
ici valérie et matthieu delormeau
[Musique]
je vous présenterai à 10h mélanger
dr
je soufflerai
derrière des grilles
ces valeurs se défendre vous dire
benayoun
c'est vrai j'ai refusé quoi dernièrement
[Rires]
ça et refuser que je vous appelle non
non un goût de quoi quand même vous avez
refusé quad amèrement forespect si vous
mettez le respecter avec tes pas
d'animateur de ses huit respecter la
star d'nrj12 de content de ce que vous
venez de dire en tout cas valérie était
soit très chaud ce jour là soit qu'est
ce qui s'est passé keïta qui rigole à
des très maladroite car juste après sa
réaction aux compliments prévu par
mathieu pour christine bravo je sais pas
si c'était très flatteur pour isabelle
en fait vous deviez écrire un tweet à
christine bravo bas mais du coup j'ai
mis chère christine séjourné du
compliment alors je n'en fais un vous
ressemble de plus en plus à isabelle
morini bosc le compliment vallée de
camilla belle c'est bien non mais non
c'est non
[Rires]
mais attention ça valse et amateurs
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça rien à
voir c'est ma tension jouer elle elle
sait se défendre et toutes les passions
vous qui soutenez briquet ces peluches
foutriquet la bourrique mais
quelques-uns des mecs c'est moi j'ai
donc un moteur tourne et moi j'adore ton
truc jamais la salle des conneries tony
scott dans ouais alors donc vous avez vu
que benjamin en plus pour rajouter un
petit smic dernières années il est bien
nous sommes de la délicatesse a été
atteint lors de la venue de stéphane
plaza nous présenter sa bd alors je sais
pas si les chroniqueurs l'on apprécié
cette bd mais en tout cas si c'est le
cas ils n'ont pas trouvé les bons mots
pour lui dire les balourds de la semaine
tu sais le temps des conflits l'on sait
faire des confidences d'essentiel train
de complètement rouge as tu peux me l'a
dédicacé au bras de la valeur ces axes
étaient pourris c'est non encore mieux
il fallait dire voulait aller à faire
mais c'est heureux voilà forts
compliquant sa merci mais bon il y en a
un peu plus doux mais quand même
alors et on commence par une anecdote
étrange de cyril qui a voué à patrick
timsit que plus jeunes alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas connues il l'avait suivi
deux heures dans les rayons d'un
supermarché will avant de faire la télé
cyril était déjà bizarre
ça fait beaucoup de tours et rien
acheter là j'étais juste un truc quoi tu
as fais plein de combat âpre et acheter
un truc c'est que je cherchais quelque
chose en particulier sa x
[Applaudissements]
oui il a jamais regardé ce vol de sa vie
malheureusement parce qu'ils sont
messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ballet de un froid golden même couple
[Musique]
là
elle a dévoilé on exclut des extraits
suisse de son livre voilà dans l
si dur et la nuit si tendre et la vie on
dirait un truc pour un fromage
[Applaudissements]
chaque gâteau one man show aussi parce
qu'il ya des missions bien sûr qui
cartonne et qu'on adore sur le groupe
tout le groupe canal est derrière toi
doit laisser la pâte clic a fait couler
de l'eau trop là là où vous prenez donc
vous l'ajoutez c'est jean michel aphatie
en a découlé partout partout jusque
monsieur poulpe c'est normal que deux
soeurs jumelles se retrouver aux prises
ensemble elles sont nées d'une même
cellule
[Applaudissements]
des séquences à l'arrêt
[Musique]
merci le shérif